This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Due to the graphic nature of this program, the viewer discretion is advised. In 1994, an independent producer made a short-earness video featuring an eccentric cast of characters who are focused on a very specific paranoia. In Satanic occultism, that which is good is bad, and that which is bad is good. And as you view this learning and educational tape, pay attention to notice the reverse of everything that is normal becoming abnormal. The video is released as a one hour and 15 minute VHS tape. Best producer, Harmon Leon. The tape was made to look like a TV news special. It opens with a cheap, Jerry Springer era computer graphic of a gold pentagram set against
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。由于本节目包含图形化内容，建议观众自行斟酌。1994年，一位独立制片人制作了一段短片，片中汇集了一群古怪的角色，他们专注于一种非常具体的偏执。在撒旦崇拜中，好的即是坏的，坏的即是好的。当您观看这段学习和教育录像带时，请注意观察所有正常事物如何变得不正常。这段视频以一小时15分钟的VHS录像带形式发行。制片人是哈蒙·莱昂。录像带被制作成电视新闻专题片的样子。它以一个廉价的、杰瑞·斯普林格时代的电脑图形开场，背景是一个金色的五角星，衬托在
a red brick wall. There are many crimes that are unsolved in our cities, and many of those crimes have ritualistic overtones. And so today we hope to be able to shed some light on a dark, dark area. There's an impassioned host sporting a nappy sweater the color of wet cement. His title on screen reads, Cop slash Pasteur.
一面红砖墙上。在我们的城市里，有许多悬而未决的罪案，其中许多罪案带有仪式色彩。因此，今天我们希望能揭开这一黑暗、阴暗领域的真相。一位充满激情的节目主持人穿着一件湿水泥色的针织毛衣。屏幕上显示的头衔是“警察兼牧师”。
Behind me is the city of San Francisco, a city known for the first Satanic church in America. Anton LeBae established this church under the freedoms of our country in 1966 and wrote the Satanic Bible. The video was called Law Enforcement Guide to Satanic Colts. It was used by police departments as official training the satanic Bible. understand and recognize which are regular offenses, those that belong to cult behaviors. This is a law enforcement problem.
我身后是旧金山市，这座城市以美国第一个撒旦教堂而闻名。安东·拉维于1966年在我国的自由原则下建立了这座教堂，并撰写了《撒旦圣经》。这段视频名为《执法人员撒旦邪教指南》。它被警察部门用作官方培训材料，以了解和识别哪些是普通犯罪，哪些属于邪教行为。这是一个执法问题。
Therefore, all law enforcement officers should be familiar with the difference. I first saw this video years ago on YouTube. What got me laughing was how ridiculous it all seems today. The bikini model with a huge pentagram drawn on her stomach, the mullet sporting so-called Satanic expert who walks us through a crime scene filled with made up Satanic symbols. I've watched the video no less than a dozen times and only gets more and more absurd
因此，所有执法人员都应该熟悉其中的区别。我几年前在YouTube上第一次看到这段视频。让我发笑的是，今天看来这一切是多么荒谬。那个肚子上画着巨大五角星的比基尼模特，那个留着鲻鱼头、带着我们参观布满伪造撒旦符号犯罪现场的所谓撒旦专家。我看了不下十几遍，而且越看越觉得荒谬。
with each viewing. But then I started looking a little closer and realized this video is once taken very seriously. a little closer and realize this video is once taken very seriously, especially by police, who used it to convince their fellow officers that they were America's first lines of defense what we now call the Satanic Panic. The Satanic Panic was based on conspiracy theories, misinformation, and straight-up lies. But back in the 1980s and early 90s, that wave of paranoia and anxiety that swept across the US felt very real.
但后来我开始仔细观察，意识到这段视频曾经被非常严肃地对待，尤其是被警察，他们用它来说服同事，他们是美国的第一道防线，这就是我们现在所说的“撒旦恐慌”。撒旦恐慌基于阴谋论、错误信息和彻头彻尾的谎言。但在20世纪80年代和90年代初，那股席卷美国的偏执和焦虑浪潮感觉非常真实。
The fear was that well-organized, secret satanic cults were lurking everywhere, corrupting America's youth. Even worse, parents lived in terror that Satanists were kidnapping children and murdering them and gruesome occult sacrifices. Everyone seemed to buy it. Parents, teachers, church leaders, and the media. The local media was inclined to believe even the most ridiculous of allotations. You know, and then you look on the national stage and have people giving space for this idea. Jordan Smith is an investigative journalist who's covered the Satanic panic and how the
当时的恐惧是，组织严密、秘密的撒旦邪教潜伏在各处，腐蚀着美国的年轻人。更糟糕的是，父母们生活在恐惧中，担心撒旦崇拜者绑架儿童，并在恐怖的邪教祭祀中杀害他们。每个人似乎都相信了。父母、老师、教会领袖和媒体。当地媒体倾向于相信即使是最荒谬的指控。你知道，当你看看全国舞台，有人为这种观点提供空间。乔丹·史密斯是一位调查记者，他报道过撒旦恐慌以及媒体是如何
press made things so much worse. I think it's, I mean, it's disappointing. It's, you know, nicest way to say it. I mean, these are people that are theoretically supposed to be calling out bullshit when they see it, but are not. Definitely not. The media mostly just fan the flames. There were dozens of documentaries and TV news specials produced on Satanism.
让事情变得更糟的。我认为这，我的意思是，这令人失望。这是，你知道，最委婉的说法。我的意思是，这些人理论上应该在看到胡说八道时指出来，但他们没有。绝对没有。媒体大多只是火上浇油。当时制作了数十部关于撒旦崇拜的纪录片和电视新闻专题片。
Talk show celebrities made exposés stoking unfounded fears about demonic cults. To describe this story as horrifying would be an undistitement. It deals with satanic cults, human sacrifices, of death. Devil worship, exposing sittings underground. There are thousands of men and women who are secretly worshipping the devil. A devil on Thursday, we discuss satanism
脱口秀名人们制作了揭露节目，煽动对恶魔邪教毫无根据的恐惧。将这个故事描述为令人毛骨悚然都算轻描淡写。它涉及撒旦邪教、活人祭祀、死亡。魔鬼崇拜，揭露地下聚会。有成千上万的男女在秘密崇拜魔鬼。周四，我们讨论撒旦崇拜。
to summit the religion, to others that's the practice of evil in the devil's name. It exists and it's flourishing. These supposed deep dives into the dangers of devil worshiping cults were wildly successful in terms of ratings. Americans couldn't get enough of the wall-to-wall satanic panic coverage. The thing that I will never understand is why somebody would believe this because it's so clearly unhinged and irrational and illogical?
对一些人来说，这是宗教；对另一些人来说，这是以魔鬼之名行恶。它确实存在，而且正在蓬勃发展。这些所谓的对魔鬼崇拜邪教危险的深入挖掘在收视率方面非常成功。美国人对铺天盖地的撒旦恐慌报道乐此不疲。我永远无法理解的是，为什么有人会相信这些，因为它显然是精神错乱、非理性和不合逻辑的？
Once the narrative got kicked off, it was just sort of an unstoppable juggernaut. But the satanic panic would have never become as big and ugly as it did without the misguided and ignorant actions of law enforcement. Gullible cops believed they were on the front lines of an all-out war against a plague of demonic crime. Law enforcement did not shy away from this role. Since the early 1980s, when the panic began, police departments had been grooming cops, whose job was to learn everything about demonic crimes.
一旦叙事开始，它就像一种不可阻挡的势头。但如果没有执法部门误导和无知的行为，撒旦恐慌绝不会变得如此巨大和丑陋。轻信的警察相信他们正处于一场针对恶魔犯罪瘟疫的全面战争的前线。执法部门并没有回避这个角色。自20世纪80年代初恐慌开始以来，警察部门一直在培养警察，他们的工作是学习关于恶魔犯罪的一切。
Most of those cops would proclaim themselves satanic experts. They would teach classes on cold crimes to their fellow officers. There were several police departments who would have an officer who would be the designated satanic crime expert and so on. They had studied the phenomenon, had declared themselves to be experts, and they were on the lecture circuit. Ken Laning is a former FBI agent who has once the nation's leading law enforcement authority on satanic crimes. I became an informal clearinghouse for these cases.
大多数警察会自称是撒旦专家。他们会向同事教授邪教犯罪课程。有几个警察部门会有一名警官担任指定的撒旦犯罪专家等等。他们研究过这种现象，宣布自己是专家，并活跃在讲座巡回活动中。肯·拉宁是一位前联邦调查局特工，曾是全国领先的撒旦犯罪执法权威。我成了这些案件的非正式信息交换中心。
Satanic ritual abuse called Ken Laning at the FBI, And so I just started to deal with hundreds of these cases. Today, Ken is very critical of the so-called experts. Those cops who relied on a jumble of newspaper clippings, police reports, and sensational documentaries to teach their fellow officers. Police were particularly fond of heraldra Rivera's NBC special on Satanism, which earned huge ratings when it ran on TV in 1988.
撒旦仪式虐待案件都打给FBI的肯·拉宁，于是我开始处理数百起这类案件。今天，肯对那些所谓的专家非常批评。那些依靠一堆剪报、警察报告和耸人听闻的纪录片来教导同事的警察。警察特别喜欢杰拉尔多·里维拉在NBC制作的关于撒旦崇拜的专题片，该片在1988年电视播出时获得了极高的收视率。
It's teenagers who are most likely to fall under the spell of this jumble of dark, violent emotions called Satanism, and in some cases to be driven into committing terrible deeds. When heraldor special came out, because a lot of cops are looking for audiovisual material and shortcuts, make a copy of it over the VCR, pop it in the tape, and now you're playing Araldo's two hour special that we've shown on television as if it's a documented training film for law enforcement.
青少年最容易受到这种被称为撒旦崇拜的黑暗、暴力情绪的蛊惑，在某些情况下会被驱使去做出可怕的行为。当杰拉尔多的专题片出来时，因为很多警察在寻找视听材料和捷径，他们用录像机录下来，放进录像带，然后播放杰拉尔多在电视上播出的两小时专题片，就好像它是执法部门的纪录片培训教材一样。
And then in 1994, that law enforcement audience got exactly the kind of video it was looking for, a training tape about satanic cults that was tailor-made for cops. The idea for the video came from a small-time filmmaker named Devon Dahavan. Back in the early 1990s, Dahavan was a young producer based in San Diego, just trying to break into the film industry. Yeah, incredible energy. He's really ambitious. He could get so much done in 24 hours. This is Carrie Burton's scene. He worked closely with Dahavan back in the 90s.
然后在1994年，执法部门的观众得到了他们想要的那种视频，一段为警察量身定做的关于撒旦邪教的培训录像带。这个视频的想法来自一位名叫德文·达哈文的小型电影制作人。早在20世纪90年代初，达哈文是一位住在圣地亚哥的年轻制片人，正试图打入电影行业。是的，精力惊人。他非常有野心。他能在24小时内完成很多事情。这是凯莉·伯顿的场景。他在90年代与达哈文密切合作。
Although Dahavan went and talked to me for this story, Carrie shared pretty freely his memories of how driven Dahavan was. He was constantly juggling numerous projects from directing small music videos to shooting boring corporate films. His dream was always to become a big producer. He had some real goals inside. I mean, one of the things that he was really good at recognizing was that if you could get somebody to pay you to have a camera in your hands, that time becomes really valuable. For one of his projects, Dahavan made a half-hour documentary aimed at teaching parents about
虽然达哈文没有为这个故事接受我的采访，但凯莉非常自由地分享了他对达哈文有多么拼命的记忆。他不断地同时处理多个项目，从导演小型音乐录影带到拍摄枯燥的企业宣传片。他的梦想一直是成为一名大制片人。他内心有一些真正的目标。我的意思是，他非常擅长认识到的一点是，如果你能让人付钱让你手里拿着摄像机，那么时间就变得非常有价值。为了他的一个项目，达哈文制作了一部半小时的纪录片，旨在教导父母关于
the dangers of Satanism. Then he started developing another video on the same subject, but instead of a demonic occultism warning that felt like a PSA, this new project would focus specifically on cops. There was already a built in market for something like this. As the go-to experts on Satanic crimes, cops were the stars of the moment. They were the ones educating the public about the alleged ritual abuse crisis
撒旦崇拜的危险。然后他开始开发另一个关于同一主题的视频，但这个新项目不再是像公共服务广告那样的恶魔崇拜警告，而是专门针对警察。这种东西已经有了现成的市场。作为撒旦犯罪的权威专家，警察是当时的明星。他们是向公众宣传所谓的仪式虐待危机的人，
in which they also got to play the heroes. But there weren't any videos made specifically to teach police how to spot satanic crimes. Dahavan's video would satisfy that need. To get the tape made and in the hands of law enforcement, Dahavan called up the guy he often rented his video equipment from. Hello, I'm Lenny McGill. And as I stand before you, I have honor about my person concealed 11 different handguns. I would describe Lenny McGill as the Joe exotic of guns.
在危机中他们也扮演了英雄的角色。但没有任何视频是专门教警察如何识别撒旦犯罪的。达哈文的视频将满足这一需求。为了制作录像带并将其交到执法部门手中，达哈文打电话给他经常租用视频设备的人。你好，我是兰尼·麦吉尔。当我站在你们面前时，我身上藏着11把不同的手枪。我会把兰尼·麦吉尔描述为枪支界的“乔·异国情调”。
Back in the early 90s, instead of selling firearms, Lenny made his money producing his own brand of very niche VHS tapes. I formed a business called Got Video. And it was actually a good business. You know, we basically did a whole series of videotapes on fire arms. Lenny made instructional videotapes on all aspects of gun use. And he sold those tapes through his mail order catalog. That catalog in Lenny's gun videos were very popular among law enforcement.
早在90年代初，兰尼不是卖枪，而是通过制作自己品牌的非常小众的VHS录像带赚钱。我成立了一家名为“Got Video”的企业。这实际上是一门好生意。你知道，我们基本上制作了一整套关于枪支的录像带。兰尼制作了关于枪支使用各个方面的教学录像带。他通过邮购目录销售这些录像带。那个目录和兰尼的枪支视频在执法部门中非常受欢迎。
That's the exact audience, Devon D. Havan, hope to reach. He needed Lenny's help to shoot and market his new video project. So they struck a deal. Lenny would be the executive producer of Devon's new satanic video, and he'd get a cut of the sales.
这正是德文·达哈文希望接触到的受众。他需要兰尼的帮助来拍摄和营销他的新视频项目。于是他们达成了一项协议。兰尼将担任德文新撒旦视频的执行制片人，他将从销售额中分一杯羹。
In exchange, Devon got to use Lenny's cameras for free and he got Lenny to agree to sell the tape in his catalog. Devon and his small crew wrote and shot the video over several months, mostly in San Francisco and San Diego. They pulled together several supposed experts, including that mullet sporting ex-high priests. One hardened detective shows just how supposedly elaborate and pervasive these demonic cults were, pointing to a calendar of sacrificial holidays and a glossary of satanic terms.
作为交换，德文可以免费使用兰尼的摄像机，并让兰尼同意在他的目录中销售该录像带。德文和他的小团队在几个月内编写并拍摄了这段视频，主要是在旧金山和圣地亚哥。他们召集了几位所谓的专家，包括那个留着鲻鱼头的前大祭司。一位经验丰富的侦探展示了这些恶魔邪教是多么复杂和普遍，指着一份祭祀节日日历和一份撒旦术语表。
All this is backed by a homemade synth soundtrack. The numbers 666. According to the Bible, these numbers 666 are the mark of the beast. The pedagram. This inverted star points downward towards hell and Satan. It is a popular simple but has no meaning other than a satanic one, and there may be many different versions. The video speaks straight to the police with the message that satanic ritual abuse is real, it is pervasive and horrific, and it's hurting the most vulnerable people. According to the tape, cops are the ones to save us,
所有这些都配有自制的合成器配乐。数字666。根据《圣经》，这三个数字666是兽的印记。五角星。这个倒置的星星指向地狱和撒旦。它是一个流行的符号，除了撒旦含义外没有其他意义，并且可能有许多不同的版本。视频直接对警察说话，传达的信息是撒旦仪式虐待是真实的，它是普遍且可怕的，它正在伤害最脆弱的人群。根据录像带，警察是拯救我们的人，
and the tape promises to show them how. Devon finished editing the video in 1994, and then he made a very smart marketing move. Just to make sure he got the attention of police, he slapped a sticker on each VHS case that read, Officer Training Purposes Only. Unauthorized viewers may be subject to prosecution under penalty of law. It was a completely unenforceable and bogus warning, but it was meant to sell the idea that this was not just your average documentary. Even though anyone could purchase the tape through Lenny McGill's gun video catalog,
录像带承诺向他们展示如何做到这一点。德文在1994年完成了视频剪辑，然后他采取了一个非常聪明的营销举措。为了确保引起警察的注意，他在每个VHS盒子上贴了一个标签，上面写着：“仅供警官培训使用。未经授权的观看者可能会受到法律制裁。”这是一个完全无法执行且虚假的警告，但它的目的是推销这样一个概念：这不仅仅是你普通的纪录片。尽管任何人都可以通过兰尼·麦吉尔的枪支视频目录购买该录像带，
that sticker gave the tape the air of official police business. As agreed, Lenny McGill listed the tape in his gun video catalog. It wasn't as big a hit as Lenny's other titles like Rock and Roll 3, Sexy Girls, Sexy Guns, but for police who are running sessions about Satanism at conferences around the US, the 75 minute BHS tape was a godsend. A lot of times the instructor would be given discretion as to what he might use or show during the training, and a lot of times videos are good. And a lot of times if it was something that you could use to give you a break in your presentation, it was something that kept the class interesting you might use it. Weaving all the weird and dangerous myths of the Satanic panic into a single video,
那个标签给了录像带一种官方警务工作的氛围。按照约定，兰尼·麦吉尔将该录像带列入了他的枪支视频目录。它不像兰尼的其他作品（如《摇滚3》、《性感女孩、性感枪支》）那样大受欢迎，但对于在美国各地的会议上举办撒旦崇拜讲座的警察来说，这盘75分钟的VHS录像带简直是天赐之物。很多时候，讲师可以自行决定在培训期间使用或展示什么，很多时候视频效果很好。如果它是你可以用来在演讲中休息一下的东西，并且能让课程保持有趣，你可能会使用它。将撒旦恐慌中所有怪异和危险的神话编织成一个单一的视频，
law enforcement guide to Satanic cults was widely circulated. Maybe you think your community is immune to these satanic crimes. Well, it's not. I challenge you to investigate each crime just a little bit deeper. Let's stop this heinous crime that's going on in the name of the devil. Let's stop it before it takes another victim. But this tape had a lot of the same problems as all the other fear-mongering media of that era.
《执法人员撒旦邪教指南》被广泛传播。也许你认为你的社区对这些撒旦犯罪免疫。好吧，事实并非如此。我挑战你对每起犯罪进行更深入的调查。让我们停止这种以魔鬼之名进行的令人发指的罪行。让我们在它夺走下一个受害者之前阻止它。但这段录像带和那个时代所有其他煽动恐惧的媒体一样，存在很多相同的问题。
First of all, it trains police to be on the lookout for so-called Davelers. These were people who did things that were supposedly satanic-ish, like listening to heavy metal music, playing Dungeons and Dragons, or just being queer. Another problem with the video was that it featured someone claiming that they were abused by Satanists as a kid. These kinds of repressed memory testimonies were widely discredited by the mid-1990s. Psychotherapists were criticized for coursing children into saying whatever they thought the adults wanted to hear.
首先，它训练警察去寻找所谓的“魔鬼崇拜者”。这些人做的事情被认为是撒旦式的，比如听重金属音乐、玩《龙与地下城》，或者仅仅是酷儿。视频的另一个问题是，它采访了一个声称自己小时候被撒旦崇拜者虐待的人。到90年代中期，这类压抑记忆的证词已被广泛质疑。心理治疗师因强迫儿童说出他们认为成年人想听的话而受到批评。
But the biggest issue with law enforcement guide to Satanic cults is how much it was probably just made up. You know, for me, I was a little bit uncomfortable with the level of dramatic presentation. This is Carrie Burton's senior again, Devon to Havan hired Carrie to be his production manager on the project. Carrie admits that the tape was shot less like a fact-based training video and more like a film where Devon took a lot of creative license. Carrie believes some of the so-called proof of demonic rituals in the video, like the Satanic
但《执法人员撒旦邪教指南》最大的问题在于它有多少内容可能纯属捏造。你知道，对我来说，我对这种戏剧性的呈现水平感到有点不舒服。这是凯莉·伯顿·塞尼，德文·达哈文聘请凯莉担任该项目的制作经理。凯莉承认，录像带的拍摄与其说是基于事实的培训视频，不如说是一部电影，德文在其中发挥了很大的创作自由。凯莉认为视频中一些所谓的恶魔仪式证据，比如到处喷涂的撒旦
graffiti spray-painted everywhere, was staged by one of the experts in the video. We looked like it was done on purpose for us, because there was pretty consistent in its presentation. But now, right over here, I can see on a tree here, there's a inverted cross. Now this is satanic. This is a very generic symbol. Let me see. Well, it's actually fairly fresh, too.
涂鸦，是由视频中的一位专家策划的。我们看起来好像是专门为我们做的，因为它的呈现方式非常一致。但现在，就在这里，我可以在树上看到一个倒十字。这是撒旦的。这是一个非常通用的符号。让我看看。嗯，它实际上也相当新鲜。
Obviously, they probably had a party or a ritual here within the past and the night or two. Usually what they'll do is... Looking back, Carrie says a lot of Devon's production choices seem to follow this pattern of make believe. I think he may have embellished some of it. You know, a lot of what gets labeled as a dynamic activity is really just
显然，他们可能在过去的一两天里在这里举行过聚会或仪式。通常他们会做的是……回想起来，凯莉说德文的很多制作选择似乎都遵循这种假装的模式。我认为他可能夸大了一些。你知道，很多被贴上恶魔活动标签的东西实际上只是
some kids goofing around, but you know, that's not a very interesting video to say that. But the thing is back in the 1990s, goofing around, but you know that's not a very interesting video to say that. But the thing is back in the 1990s cops didn't see any of this as just goofing around. The satanic panic stirred up a zealotry among police officers who became radicalized against Satanism, particularly some Christian cops who literally believed they were doing God's work by hunting demons. Some of the cops were true believers. They believe in all of this and they think they did doing a good thing to make society aware of it and to save abuse children and expose what's going on. Since his days as the FBI's number one Satanism expert. Ken Lening has become super critical
一些孩子在胡闹，但你知道，说那是胡闹并不是一个非常有趣的视频。但问题是，在20世纪90年代，警察并没有把这一切仅仅看作是胡闹。撒旦恐慌在警察中激起了一种狂热，他们对撒旦崇拜变得激进，特别是那些真正相信自己通过猎杀恶魔来履行上帝旨意的基督徒警察。有些警察是真正的信徒。他们相信这一切，他们认为自己在做一件好事，让社会意识到这一点，拯救受虐待的儿童并揭露正在发生的事情。自担任FBI头号撒旦崇拜专家以来，肯·拉宁变得非常挑剔
of how police bought into the myths and conspiracies of the Satanic panic. I would like to tell you that law enforcement officers are always neutral and objective. Fact finders have got their minds on straight. But I found that police officers are just as likely or can be just as easily influenced by the emotion of something like satanic crime.
关于警察是如何相信撒旦恐慌的神话和阴谋的。我想告诉你们，执法人员总是中立和客观的。事实调查者头脑清醒。但我发现警察同样容易受到像撒旦犯罪这类事情的情绪影响。
As Ken Laning looked closer at all the cases of supposed demonic abuse that had piled up on his desk during the 1980s and 90s, things just weren't adding up. There was often nothing to corroborate and investigators claim that a crime was, quote, unquote, satanic. And when Laning would ask for proof,
当肯·拉宁仔细审视他在80年代和90年代堆积在办公桌上的所有所谓的恶魔虐待案件时，事情根本对不上号。调查人员声称犯罪是“撒旦式”的，但往往没有任何证据支持。当拉宁要求提供证据时，
he'd get all kinds of ridiculous excuses. I'd say, okay, what's the evidence? And then they would explain to you why there wasn't any evidence. That was the evidence that there was no evidence. Lanny says detectives would often tell him that the evidence of ritual abuse had just vanished. They'd say it was because they were dealing with the dark forces of Satan who had the power to conceal it. So their proof of it was that the fact that there was no proof. All the lies, conspiracies, and satanic profiling, it all had real and tragic consequences. During the 1980s and 90s, nearly 200 people were charged with satanic ritual abuse crimes.
他会得到各种荒谬的借口。我会说，好吧，证据是什么？然后他们会向你解释为什么没有任何证据。这就是证据，因为没有证据。拉宁说，侦探们经常告诉他，仪式虐待的证据刚刚消失了。他们会说这是因为他们正在处理撒旦的黑暗力量，而撒旦有能力隐藏它。所以他们证明其存在的证据就是没有证据这一事实。所有的谎言、阴谋和撒旦侧写，都产生了真实而悲惨的后果。在20世纪80年代和90年代，近200人被指控犯有撒旦仪式虐待罪。
Dozens were convicted and served long prison sentences. Some are still behind bars. In just one case that helped define the era, four openly gay women in San Antonio, Texas were convicted of sexually assaulting two children in 1994. The crime was alleged to be, quote unquote, satanic-related. The women received sentences ranging from 15 to more than 37 years. The case was clearly part of a homophobic witch hunt, and the accusations were completely baseless. All four women were eventually exonerated, but only after spending a decade and a half in prison. By the second half of the 1990s, a million holes had been poked in the satanic panic conspiracy in a half in prison.
数十人被定罪并服了长期刑期。有些人至今仍在狱中。在定义了那个时代的一个案件中，1994年，德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市的四名公开的女同性恋者被判性侵两名儿童。该罪行被指控为“撒旦相关”。这些女性被判处15年至37年以上的刑期。此案显然是一场恐同猎巫行动的一部分，指控完全毫无根据。这四名女性最终都被平反，但那是在她们在监狱里度过了十五年之后。到90年代下半叶，撒旦恐慌阴谋论中已经被戳出了无数个洞。
By the second half of the 1990s, a million holes had been poked in the Satanic Panic conspiracy theories. People stopped believing that daycare centers were fronts for child-sacrified ceremonies, at least for the time being, and no one cared anymore if Satanic messages were hidden in rock music. And so about a year or two after a law enforcement to say Tannik Colts was released, Ken landing says the national panic over demonic abuse really began
到90年代下半叶，撒旦恐慌阴谋论中已经被戳出了无数个洞。人们不再相信日托中心是儿童祭祀仪式的幌子，至少暂时如此，也没人再关心摇滚乐中是否隐藏着撒旦信息。因此，在《执法人员撒旦邪教指南》发行一两年后，肯·拉宁说，全国范围内对恶魔虐待的恐慌真的开始
to fade. A lot of people just wanted it to go away. They were embarrassed that they had once believed that was going on and they just quietly just walked away from it. Then the media turned on it as well, and the media started to do a lot of negative stories about it and point out the absurdity.
消退了。很多人只是想让它消失。他们为自己曾经相信这种事情正在发生而感到尴尬，于是他们悄悄地走开了。然后媒体也转向了，媒体开始做很多关于它的负面报道，并指出其荒谬之处。
Heraldo came out and publicly apologized for all his devil-worship exposés. As for the police, landing says most of them just moved on. Police departments around the country quietly stopped using the Law Enforcement Guide to Satanic cult video. The tape disappeared from police training sessions, along with the phrase, Satanic, ritual abuse. Producer Devon DeHavn never made anything quite like this tape ever again. His co-creator, Carrie Burton-Ceney, says, Devon got exactly what he wanted out of that
杰拉尔多出来公开为他所有的魔鬼崇拜揭露节目道歉。至于警察，拉宁说他们大多数人只是继续前进。全国各地的警察部门悄悄停止使用《执法人员撒旦邪教指南》视频。这盘录像带从警察培训课程中消失了，连同“撒旦仪式虐待”这个词一起。制片人德文·达哈文再也没有制作过类似的东西。他的联合创作者凯莉·伯顿·塞尼说，德文从那次
production. It got his name out there. It's got him working in different locations with equipment and a team. So at his age and at the time, it was a pretty good feather in his cap. And it was mostly about making a video that that's going to help move him forward. The Havan did law enforcement guide to Satanic cults nearly 30 years ago in hopes of making a name for himself. With this tape as one of his first IMDB credits, he's gone on to produce and direct nearly
制作中得到了他想要的一切。它让他的名字传了出去。它让他带着设备和团队在不同的地方工作。所以在他那个年龄和当时的情况下，这对他来说是一个相当不错的成就。这主要是为了制作一个能帮助他前进的视频。达哈文在近30年前制作了《执法人员撒旦邪教指南》，希望能为自己扬名。随着这盘录像带成为他最早的IMDB作品之一，他后来制作并导演了近
300 different projects from deaf comedy jam to the very not not Satanic Kiss Monster World Tour. world to her. Even though I couldn't get DeHaven to talk to me for this story, he did send me an email in which he said, Going back to Law Enforcement thing, that's so far in the past, I don't even remember those docks. Law Enforcement guide to Satanic cults lives on with a newfound audience. The artist's collective, Everything is Terrible, has screened excerpts at their found footage festival where viewers would point and laugh at the idea that anyone in their right mind
300个不同的项目，从《Def Comedy Jam》到非常不撒旦的“Kiss Monster”世界巡回演唱会。尽管我无法让达哈文接受我的采访，但他确实给我发了一封电子邮件，其中他说：“回到执法那件事，那已经是过去很久的事了，我甚至不记得那些纪录片了。”《执法人员撒旦邪教指南》在新的观众群中得以延续。艺术家团体“Everything is Terrible”在他们的“发现录像带节”上放映了片段，观众们指着屏幕嘲笑那些头脑正常的人
ever took any of this stuff seriously. Nick Mara is the co-founder of Everything is Terrible, and he's a big fan of the police training tape. I just watched it today, and it was... I saw all kinds of things that I had missed the first seven times I watched it. Just stuffed full of goodies. They were using this tape that is so clearly full of just bullshit, and they're training police officers with this. After the satanic panic, you'd think that we'd be wiser as a culture, but then there's PTAK and QAnon.
竟然会认真对待这些东西。尼克·马拉是“Everything is Terrible”的联合创始人，他是这盘警察培训录像带的忠实粉丝。我今天刚看了它，它是……我看到了我前七次观看时错过的各种东西。简直塞满了宝贝。他们竟然用这盘显然全是胡说八道的录像带去培训警察。在撒旦恐慌之后，你本以为我们作为一个文化会更明智，但后来又有了PTAK和QAnon。
It's just a constant rebranding of the same bullshit to keep people scared and in prison. And I think until the major structures of our civilization and the priorities of the civilization change, it's going to be the same shit. It's impossible to trace exactly how much law enforcement guide to satanic cults was responsible for all the myths that ruin people's lives during the satanic panic. But as an artifact of that era, it shows how conspiracies
这只是同一种胡说八道的不断重塑，为了让人们保持恐惧并被囚禁。我认为，除非我们文明的主要结构和文明的优先事项发生改变，否则情况还会是同样的烂摊子。追踪《执法人员撒旦邪教指南》在多大程度上导致了撒旦恐慌期间毁掉人们生活的所有神话是不可能的。但作为那个时代的文物，它展示了阴谋
can easily balloon into the official story. And it's not just a story, it's not just a story. It's not just a story, it's not just a story. during the satanic panic. But as an artifact of that era, it shows how conspiracies can easily balloon into the official story, and how easy it is to slap on a sticker with an official sounding warning that seems to give these conspiracies the power and authority of law.
如何轻易地膨胀成官方故事。这不仅仅是一个故事，这不仅仅是一个故事。这不仅仅是一个故事，这不仅仅是一个故事。在撒旦恐慌期间。但作为那个时代的文物，它展示了阴谋如何轻易地膨胀成官方故事，以及贴上一个带有官方听起来的警告标签是多么容易，这似乎赋予了这些阴谋法律的力量和权威。
After the break, a different story about finding the devil in a remote stretch of highway. Sometimes associations with the devil appear in the smallest details. Once you have to look carefully in old road atlases to find, reporter Austin Cope has the story. There's a highway near where I grew up about half an hour's drive from the New Mexico border. It runs through some of the more remote parts half an hour's drive from the New Mexico border. It runs through some of the more remote parts of the U.S., Northern New Mexico, Southern Utah, and my own hometown of Cortez, in southwestern Colorado. Along the route, smooth tan sandstone cliffs and jagged brown rock formations rise up over
休息之后，一个关于在偏远公路寻找魔鬼的不同故事。有时与魔鬼的联系出现在最小的细节中。一旦你必须仔细查看旧的公路地图集才能找到，记者奥斯汀·科普带来了这个故事。在我长大的地方附近有一条高速公路，距离新墨西哥州边境大约半小时车程。它穿过美国一些更偏远的地区，新墨西哥州北部、犹他州南部，以及我自己的家乡——科罗拉多州西南部的科尔特斯。沿途，平滑的棕褐色砂岩悬崖和锯齿状的棕色岩层耸立在
the high desert. Hot sun and giant thunder clouds fill the sky in summer. Cold winds and dust storms blow over it in the winter and spring. The highway was called US Route 666. Some locals called it Triple Six, or the highway to hell. Most people I knew talked about it like a novelty. We had the devil's highway running through our town. The link between 666 and the devil comes from the Bible.
高沙漠之上。夏天，炎热的太阳和巨大的雷云填满了天空。冬天和春天，寒风和沙尘暴吹过它。这条高速公路被称为美国666号公路。一些当地人称它为“三六”或“通往地狱的高速公路”。我认识的大多数人都把它当作一种新奇事物来谈论。我们镇上有一条魔鬼公路。666与魔鬼之间的联系来自《圣经》。
A passage in chapter 13 of the book of Revelation reads, Let the person who has insight calculate the number of the beast, for it is the number of a man. That number is 666. This association has led some people to feel really nervous about the number. Enough people that they invented a needlessly complicated name for a fear of 6666. It's called the Hexicosioihexiconta Hexophobia. But the origin of how the highway became known as 6666 is slightly less eventful than the book of Revelation. It got its number through an aberration of the early days of the US numbered highway
《启示录》第13章的一段经文写道：“在这里有智慧。凡有聪明的，可以算计兽的数目，因为这是人的数目，他的数目是六百六十六。”这种联系导致一些人对这个数字感到非常紧张。足够多的人发明了一个不必要的复杂名称来形容对666的恐惧。它被称为“六百六十六恐惧症”。但这条公路如何被称为666的起源，比《启示录》中的描述要平淡得多。它通过美国编号公路系统早期的偏差获得了这个数字。
system. That's the set of guidelines that dictated how highways were arranged over the country as they were being built. Route 666 was connected to the more famous East West Highway Route 66. That's Strait Trim Chicago to Los Angeles. Its number was finalized in the 1920s, and engineers planned to have several smaller routes branching off of it, known as Spurs. They assigned a three-digit number to each Spur, all of them ending in 66. So Highway 1-66 would start in Kansas, 2-66 in Oklahoma, 3-66 in Texas, and so on from East to West. Highway 6-66 was a 6 designated Spur along the way. For the isolated parts of the country these highways went through, like Rigerup, these routes ended up becoming
这是一套规定公路在建设时如何跨国排列的准则。666号公路与更著名的东西向公路66号公路相连。那是从芝加哥到洛杉矶的直达路线。它的编号在20世纪20年代最终确定，工程师计划让几条较小的路线从它分叉出来，称为“支线”。他们为每条支线分配了一个三位数的编号，全部以66结尾。所以166号公路从堪萨斯州开始，266号在俄克拉荷马州，366号在德克萨斯州，以此类推，从东到西。666号公路是沿途指定的第6条支线。对于这些公路穿过的偏远地区，比如我长大的地方，这些路线最终成为了
major thoroughfares. I also grew up next to the highway, um, went to school in Gallup, and it had been until hatching New Mexico. And along that, for about 30 miles along, highway 666, and it did have a lot of stigma to it as far as when we talk about the religious numbers. New Mexico State Senator Shannon Pinto represents one of the districts the highway runs through. She also represents some of the overlapping boundaries
主要干道。我也在公路旁边长大，在盖洛普上学，一直到新墨西哥州的哈奇。沿着这条路，大约30英里的666号公路，当我们谈论宗教数字时，它确实有很多污名。新墨西哥州参议员香农·平托代表了公路穿过的选区之一。她还代表了一些重叠的边界
of the Navajo nation. She's Navajo, and most of her family lives in the area. There was no way you couldn't get to where you needed to without driving the highway, you know. You couldn't try to hold to your beliefs if you were religious About the six six number and well, I'm not gonna drive that highway As Pinto was growing up in the 1980s and 90s
纳瓦霍族领地。她是纳瓦霍人，她的大部分家人都住在这个地区。如果不开车走这条公路，你根本无法到达你需要去的地方。如果你是一个宗教人士，你无法坚持你的信仰，关于666这个数字，好吧，我不会开那条公路。当平托在20世纪80年代和90年代长大时，
It was hard to ignore the connection between the highway cutting through that area and the number of the beast Lots of hard rock music had started to become popular among people on the reservation There was deaf leopard monthly multi-crucans and roses, iron maiden, pantera, mega death, skid row came out. There was a lot of metal bands during that time.
很难忽视穿过该地区的公路与兽的数字之间的联系。很多硬摇滚音乐开始在保留地的人们中流行起来。有Def Leppard、Mötley Crüe、Guns N' Roses、Iron Maiden、Pantera、Megadeth、Skid Row。那个时期有很多金属乐队。
Six, six, six, six, and no more of a beast. How? In 1994, the bad vibes kept coming when Oliver Stone's film Natural Born Killers came out. It had an ultra-violent plot that followed a couple of serial killers. Part of the film was shot in Gallup and directly references the local highway. Tonight, I'm standing on Highway 666, running through Tans like Cortez, Shiprock, Sheep Springs,
六、六、六，兽的数字。怎么回事？1994年，当奥利弗·斯通的电影《天生杀人狂》上映时，坏氛围持续不断。它有一个超暴力的情节，讲述了一对连环杀手。电影的一部分是在盖洛普拍摄的，并直接提到了当地的高速公路。今晚，我站在666号公路上，穿过像科尔特斯、希普罗克、希普斯普林斯这样的城镇，
and ending in Gallup, New Mexico. To some, a beautiful stretch of the American landscape. But to Mickey and Mallory not, we're still at large. It is literally a candy lane of murder and may." Pinto says that it wasn't just Uber violent movies and death metal that freaked locals out. The highway had a reputation for being dangerous in real life, too. Collisions were common. She remembers someone from the tribal office
最后到达新墨西哥州的盖洛普。对一些人来说，这是一段美丽的美国风景。但对米奇和马洛里来说，我们仍然在逃。这简直是一条谋杀和混乱的糖果巷。”平托说，不仅仅是超级暴力的电影和死亡金属让当地人感到恐惧。这条公路在现实生活中也以危险著称。碰撞很常见。她记得有人来自部落办公室
of Environmental Health coming into her middle school to talk about DWIs. And she showed us these maps of all these fatal collisions along Highway 666. It was a pretty high number, just even for the population per capita within the area. Between 1979 and 2000, New Mexico's transportation department counted over 6,500 crashes between Gallup and the Colorado border.
环境卫生部门来到她的中学谈论酒驾。她给我们看了这些沿着666号公路发生的所有致命碰撞的地图。这个数字相当高，即使对于该地区的人均人口来说也是如此。1979年至2000年间，新墨西哥州交通部门统计了盖洛普和科罗拉多州边境之间超过6,500起车祸。
The Albuquerque Journal tellied 22 pedestrians killed between 1985 and 1992 within a mile stretch. One state trooper even recalled a drunk driving suspect telling him, triple six is evil. Everyone dies on that highway. And Pinto says there was violence in the region. She told me about a young Navajo girl who disappeared near the highway in the mid 80s.
《阿尔伯克基日报》统计了1985年至1992年间在一英里路段内有22名行人死亡。一名州警甚至回忆说，一名酒驾嫌疑人告诉他：“三六是邪恶的。每个人都死在那条公路上。”平托说该地区确实存在暴力。她告诉我一个年轻的纳瓦霍女孩在80年代中期在公路附近失踪的事。
That case wasn't the first or the last. Gallup still has one of the highest rates of missing and murdered indigenous women and girls in the US. There were also issues related to drugs and alcohol that stem from the towns along the reservation's borders and along the highway. For a lot of people in the area, it was hard to tell if the road's pop culture perception influences real life danger or vice versa. I think when there was an accident, you wondered. You wondered if there was something a little more to it. She says that a lot of people in the Navajo Nation took issue with the name of Route 666.
那个案件不是第一个，也不是最后一个。盖洛普仍然是美国原住民妇女和女孩失踪和被谋杀率最高的地区之一。还有与保留地边界城镇和公路沿线的毒品和酒精相关的问题。对于该地区的许多人来说，很难分辨这条路的流行文化认知是影响了现实生活中的危险，还是反之亦然。我想当发生事故时，你会怀疑。你会怀疑是否还有更多原因。她说纳瓦霍族很多人对666号公路的名字有异议。
The road went directly through tribal land, and many of its safety issues had gone unaddressed for years. To her, this made the route's numbering seem even more disrespectful. It was a discomfort that went beyond hexagosioe, hexagonta, hexophobia. I think there was something with those numbers that didn't sit well just with the area. There's those that will hang on to it and feel like, you know, that it was going to play into your perception of the rest of the world that they're after you, you know, after the Navajo people.
这条路直接穿过部落土地，其许多安全问题多年来一直未得到解决。对她来说，这使得路线的编号看起来更加不尊重。这是一种超越了“六百六十六恐惧症”的不适感。我认为这些数字有些东西让该地区的人感到不舒服。有些人会坚持这一点，觉得这会影响你对世界其他地方的看法，认为他们是在针对你，你知道，针对纳瓦霍人民。
It's too suppressed to say, okay, you know, who was really in charge of putting that name on there? You know, did they do that to us purposely? Or was it really something that was oversight? And they thought, oh, over time, they'll live with it. In her view, it seemed in line with so many other things that had been imposed on the Navajo people over the years. Not only was a design of the highway bad, but for Pinto, it felt like the federal government's
说“好吧，谁真正负责把那个名字放在那里？”太压抑了。你知道，他们是故意那样对我们的吗？还是真的只是疏忽？他们想，哦，随着时间的推移，他们会习惯的。在她看来，这似乎与多年来强加给纳瓦霍人民的许多其他事情是一致的。不仅公路的设计很糟糕，而且对平托来说，联邦政府对数字符号学的漠视，与它对该地区暴力、犯罪和经济问题的漠视是一致的。这些问题需要多年才能解决，但公路的编号是相对快速且容易处理的事情。香农·平托的祖父约翰·平托也是州参议员。他从20世纪70年代一直代表该选区直到2019年去世。公路的编号在他担任新墨西哥州参议员期间并不是他的主要优先事项。他花更多时间倡导为该路线的安全改进提供资金。但是，在2003年，他共同发起了一项将名称从666更改的措施。它指出，纳瓦霍族附近的居民生活在“数字联想所造成的耻辱阴云”之下，并且
disregard of the number symbology lined up with its carelessness towards the violence in the region, as well as the crime and economic concerns. Those issues would take years to fix, but the highway's number was something that could be dealt with relatively quickly and easily. Shenipinto's grandfather, John Pinto, was also a state senator. He represented that same district from the 1970s until he died in 2019. The highway's numbering wasn't his main priority during his years in the New Mexico Senate. He spent more of his time advocating for funding for safety improvements on the route. But, in 2003, he co-sponsored a measure to change the name from 666. It stated that nearby residents on the Navajo nation lived under a, quote, cloud of a probrium created by the numbers associations, and that the
公路的声誉正在使人们避开该地区。该措施建议州交通官员尽快更改编号。该措施于2003年中期在两院获得通过。部落和州交通部门决定将666号更改为更谨慎的491号。几个月后，管理美国公路编号的机构使其正式化。我想人们对它终于发生感到宽慰。名字已经改了。
highway's reputation was making people avoid the area. The measure recommended state transportation officials changed a number as soon as possible. The measure passed both chambers in mid-2003. Tribal and state transportation departments decided to change the number 666 to the more discreet 491. A few months later, the body governing US highway numbers made it official. I think people were relieved that it finally occurred. The name has changed.
你完成了。公路工人们已经在驱魔方面得到了一些帮助。666号标志多年来一直是盗窃的热门目标，但在宣布更改后，标志盗窃案大幅增加。重新编号不到两个月后，美联社报道称，新墨西哥州和科罗拉多州所有的666号标志都被拿走了，只剩下剪断的金属桩。自名称更改以来，沿线的碰撞和死亡人数显著减少，但这与重新编号关系不大，更多是与设计有关。
You're done with it. Highway workers were already getting some help with the exorcism. The 666 science had been popular targets for theft over the years, but science stealing increased substantially after the change was announced. Less than two months after the re-numbering, the Associated Press reported that all the 666 science in New Mexico and Colorado had been taken, leaving nothing except sheared metal stubs. Since the name changed, there have been significantly fewer collisions and deaths along the route, but it had less to do with re-numbering and more to do with design.
你已经完成了。公路工人已经在寻求一些驱魔方面的帮助了。多年来，666号公路的标志一直是盗窃的热门目标，但在宣布更改编号后，偷窃标志的行为大幅增加。在重新编号不到两个月后，美联社报道称，新墨西哥州和科罗拉多州所有的666号公路标志都被偷走了，只剩下被剪断的金属桩。自从改名以来，这条路线上的碰撞和死亡事故显著减少，但这与重新编号关系不大，更多是与道路设计有关。
The biggest improvement was getting almost 100 miles of the route changed from two lanes to four, since it's like a median mediums was considered a major factor for accidents. It was a project John Pinto had pushed for over the course of his time in the state senate. He and other legislators started advocating for funding in the early 80s, but it took over 20 years for the projects to start. Between the 1990s, when it had two lanes, and the 2010s, when its expansion was completed, collisions decreased by almost half. There has been a movement over the years to rename the part of the highway that goes
最大的改进是将近100英里的路线从双车道改为四车道，因为中间隔离带被认为是导致事故的主要因素。这是约翰·平托（John Pinto）在州参议院任职期间一直推动的项目。他和其它立法者在80年代初就开始倡导资金支持，但该项目花了20多年才启动。在拥有双车道的90年代和扩建完成的2010年代之间，碰撞事故减少了近一半。多年来，一直有人提议将这条高速公路的部分路段重新命名
to New Mexico after John Pinto to honor his work. A proposal went before the Navajo Tribal Council after he died in 2019, but the naming hasn't been made official. Now, 20 years later, there's only one sign and gallop that references the former 666 below the number 491. Otherwise, there's very little trace of the previous designation. A lot of people might drive the highway without knowing it was ever there. You can still find it printed on some old maps. My parents still have a few in their car.
以约翰·平托的名字命名，以纪念他的工作。在他2019年去世后，一项提案被提交给纳瓦霍部落议会，但命名尚未正式化。现在，20年过去了，在盖洛普（Gallup）只有一个标志在491号下方提到了以前的666号公路。除此之外，几乎没有以前名称的痕迹。许多人开车经过这条公路时，可能根本不知道它曾经存在过。你仍然可以在一些旧地图上找到它。我父母的车里还有几张。
Every so often I'll pull one of them out and look for the old route. The numbers are tiny and hard to find among the hundreds of other roads in the area. If 666 has to be anywhere, maybe it's best trapped in an out-of-date map, tucked into a side door compartment, next to some old pens, and a spare pair of sunglasses. 99% invisible with producer's week by Harmon Leon and Austin Cope edited by Christopher Johnson and Vivian Leigh. Sound mixed by Martin Gonzales, original music by Swan Rial, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Special thanks this week to Jessica Romov.
每隔一段时间，我就会拿出一张来看看那条旧路线。这些数字非常小，在这一地区数百条其它道路中很难找到。如果666号公路非得存在于什么地方，也许最好是被困在一张过时的地图里，塞在侧门储物格里，旁边放着几支旧笔和一副备用太阳镜。《99%无形》（99% Invisible）本周制作人：哈蒙·莱昂（Harmon Leon）和奥斯汀·科普（Austin Cope），编辑：克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）和薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）。混音：马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales），原创音乐：斯旺·里亚尔（Swan Rial），事实核查：格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）。本周特别感谢杰西卡·罗莫夫（Jessica Romov）。
Kathy too is the executive producer Delaney Horrors, senior editor Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Baroube, Jason D'Alyone, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lash Maudon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his will logo was created by Staffin Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful.
凯西·图（Kathy Tu）是执行制片人，德莱尼·霍尔斯（Delaney Hall）是高级编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监。团队其它成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Berube）、杰森·达利昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett FitzGerald）、拉什·莫顿（Lashawn Morton）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%无形》的标志由斯塔芬·劳伦斯（Staffin Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。
Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 999PI.org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You find links to others to your shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pI.org. at 99pi.org
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99pi.org。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在99pi.org找到我喜欢的其它节目的链接，以及《99%无形》的每一期往期节目。
And, yes, Lee, well, bye, this is my show. Nice, that's my... tight knock-buff is like you both Nancy and Larry. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，李，好吧，再见，这是我的节目。很好，那是我的……敲门声就像你们俩南希和拉里。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。